[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour you know as we approach the
thanksgiving season the holiday season
i'm just grateful to be able to continue
to have these conversations because i
know these things are really important
the holidays is obviously a time where
we're tired take time and really enjoy
the company of our family and friends
but it can also be a challenging time in
a lot of ways and so i think today the
fact that we're having this conversation
about support and advocacy and resources
really timely in that sense and i'm
grateful for the two guests who are
joining me today this is their first
time actually interacting but already
have great chemistry
as i noticed off offline before we even
jumped in i anticipate they'll be
staying in touch after this as well
so the first guest i'd like to introduce
is matt kudish matt is the executive
director of the national alliance on
mental illness in new york city
and nami nyc is actually one of the
largest affiliates of nominee in the
country helping support families and
individuals affected by mental illness
and to also build better lives through
education support and advocacy
matt is someone who has been named to
city and state's health and power list
for the last three years
so he's obviously recognized for his
leadership and expertise he's also the
recipient of the beatrice m goldberg
community award by the west side
interagency council for the aging and
also
the emerging social works leadership
award from the national association of
social workers in new york city as well
he has a master's in social work from
colombia he also has a master's in
public administration from nyu and is a
fellow in the inaugural stroll
fellowship executive leadership program
at hunter college so someone who
obviously is very busy and very skilled
in his craft and we're grateful to
welcome matt to the addie howard podcast
today thanks for being here
it's a pleasure
my second guest that i'd like to
introduce is corey miner smith who is an
attorney and the author of hashtag
driven
also the founder of corey empowers and
the driven you community she's someone
who has navigated the mental health care
services industry for over 25 years
based on her family's story which i know
she'll share about likely today as well
but she's also earned a master's in
education guidance and counseling and is
a trained facilitator for nami so you
can see some of the overlap already so
i'm grateful we were able to make this
pairing work and people also know corey
as a thought leader in the social
justice space with a primary focus on
mental wellness and mental wellness
advocacy as i mentioned in 2019 she
released her now highly celebrated debut
book hashtag driven with a forward by
renowned motivational speaker les brown
she also has been involved in several
different interviews has appeared on
several platforms in the national media
space on talk shows on the audible
original we've got answers and on radio
shows like the breakfast club she's also
been recruited by different fortune 500
companies to actually talk about
leadership development and the
importance of incorporating strong and
relevant mental health care in those
conversations so again grateful to
welcome attorney cory minor smith to the
addi hour
thank you for having me it's my pleasure
to join you today oh pleasure having
both of you here um and obviously
there's so much important work that you
both do
uh in terms of
advocacy and just in your day-to-day uh
endeavors so as my listeners know i do
like to check in and see how people are
doing especially with you know some of
the heavy topics that you all are
engaged in on a daily basis as well so
want to start there and just see how
you're doing uh today of all days and
just you know in our
ongoing changing societal uh situation
as it were so matt why don't we go ahead
and start with you
yeah i appreciate the question too
because i think we don't know what's
going on for folks in the midst of these
20 months and i think i learned early on
in the pandemic that i didn't know how i
was going to feel each day until my feet
hit the floor in the morning when i got
up
so today i'm feeling really excited
energized and hopeful um and um
also at the same time balance that with
thinking about what these next few
months and winter is going to bring both
as it relates to social isolation and
and really being apart again and
pandemic surges but i'm balancing
that that keeping that in my mind while
also at the same time feeling really
grateful and um and excited
that's great and in a sense um
i also just appreciate the way that you
talked about that even in your vocation
and in your role i think it's helpful
for people to realize that even those
who are serving in organizations who are
in the mental health space doesn't mean
that you have all the answers all the
times i mean as you talked about just
not knowing how you'd feel on a specific
day and to give yourself permission
to have that unknown in a sense i think
is really important
yeah
uh corey what about you how are you at
this at this moment
well i say ditto uh matt covered it all
it's very important for us to take the
time to think about ourselves when we
help people other people on a daily
basis sometimes we
forget and or perhaps just don't make
ourselves a priority and it's important
to do that um and for me right now just
grateful not just because it's november
we're going into thanksgiving but just
overall grateful
for
safety and good health battling a little
cold but that's nothing in comparison to
other things that are going on right now
and so i'm just grateful and appreciate
the opportunity to continue to share
with social isolation by having zooms
and things that can keep us safe
but just understanding that it's
important to still do the work but we
have to make sure that we are keeping
ourselves
energized and healthy in order to
continue to do the work
that's so well said and so important i
appreciate you know the way that you all
are bringing just these i mean the
perspectives the gratefulness kind of
the reality of the unknown i think that
that's it's just healthy for us to be
able to have you know even these types
of conversation um as leaders to say
okay there are things we can look back
and be grateful for but there are also
things that we know are still
challenging even as we have that
attitude of gratefulness moving forward
so definitely appreciate the standard
and the example that you all are living
to and i know that doesn't mean it's
easy oh absolutely not
[Laughter]
yeah
but you know that going in
yeah yeah and i think you know the
pandemic really kind of shined a light
on
um how easy it is to forget how
difficult it can be you know i consider
myself to be a pretty resilient
individual and the struggle has been
real and really up and down despite
feeling incredibly grateful and
fortunate i've had my health i have not
had cover 19. i'm lucky enough to be in
a
safe house and have access to everything
that i need and this pandemic really
forced me to kind of dig deeper and say
well if i'm struggling and i see myself
as pretty resilient what must this be
like for
everyone and i think a lot of times we
hear people talk about uh that we're all
in the same boat
going through this
and i think we're all experiencing
coronavirus at the same time but our
boats look really different and that
you know some of us are on a
super yacht some of us are on a
raft that's falling apart some of us are
by ourselves in a kayak some of us are
with friends on a speedboat i mean
you know it really uh we're all on the
riding the corona river as it were
but but the journey is is very different
and i'm so grateful
for that perspective because i didn't i
didn't see it really in that same way
prior to all this happening
yes i think that's saying a lot i
appreciate that honestly as well because
even in your you know position as
someone who thinks about these topics
often even things that you're also
learning and seeing as we're going
through the pandemic um as well
corey i wonder if in your work you know
as you've been involved in advocacy as
well have you seen any shifts as we've
kind of hit the pandemic as well and
tried to think about mental health
obviously there's been more attention as
matt mentioned to the mental health
piece but any shifts that you've noticed
yes surely an increase in need and
that's why i'm very grateful for
organizations like nami the national
alliance on mental illness that have
transitioned with our world
transitioning and having these
opportunities for virtual
classes virtual seminars virtual
trainings because
mental illness or mental health
conditions do not stop because
everything else in our world has stopped
and people need these services um
and their medication and their uh
support systems the act team anyone has
the acting assertive community treatment
teams that come out and help
this pandemic doesn't stop those needs
and i'm really grateful for
organizations that found a way to
continue to keep their employees safe
and provide the services to individuals
that need it and that is those that's
for those who already were established
with the services what we see now are
people trying to deal with you know
grappling with their feelings and
emotions and losing a job or losing
family members and they don't know how
to deal with their emotions and how
they're feeling and may not know about
any of these organizations and using
them for the first time like food banks
but being grateful that these things are
here and maybe they don't want to have
to use them but they know it's there and
they can use them without shame so i
think it's very important that as we see
this increase we know there was already
a need and then that helps us as
advocates to continue to advocate for
more services more funding more
treatment because it doesn't stop if
anything it's going to increase yeah
yeah i think you're exactly right and i
love how you pointed you know paying
that as kind of two different faux signs
in a sense really pointing people's
resources are there but also making sure
more resources are available in that way
as well
and that's a good that's a helpful
segue as well because i was gonna have
you just actually talk a little bit
about you know how you got into this
work and what actual services nominee
provides for any who may not be familiar
only vaguely familiar with some of the
uh some of the work that you all do
yeah so i've been with nami new york
city for a little over four years and
prior to that i worked with older adults
and their caregivers
with a focus on alzheimer's disease and
other neurocognitive disorders so i
worked in aging for about 15 years and
then the opportunity came to move to
nami nyc and and people would say oh why
you know you've been doing working and
aging for so long why are you doing this
180 and going into this whole other
space and it really isn't a 180 there's
so much more in common um with
alzheimer's especially
um
it's not a mental illness but the stigma
is is profound the shame that it brings
to families is is just as powerful the
ability for the person who is living
with the illness to participate and play
an active role in their wellness their
recovery their well-being is is
meaningfully
impacted by each of these and the impact
on families and caregivers and
communities more generally is really
similar
and so what i found at nami nyc that's
so special is that we are a peer
organization so the mental health space
is a really crowded space
and organizations like ours that are
focused on individuals with lived
experience both people living with
mental health issues and family members
friends and other supporters
coming together to share their personal
experiences their journeys the
validation that they can share from
understanding what you're going through
because they are living it as well
it's outside the treatment
modality so but it also complements what
we do this peer support model
is complementary to every one of those
more traditional treatment kinds of
interventions so you can go to therapy
once a week you can be served by an act
team you can be in
a clubhouse program and still come to
nami nyc get support get connected find
community and a sense of
uh a sense of belonging which can be
really difficult i think so often when
people are struggling with mental health
issues they and their family members
feel so isolated and alone and we're
here we've lived it we are living it and
when you walk through our door or you
pop into one of our our virtual sessions
you're you're welcomed and you see that
the playing field is level uh that
there's really a safety and a
non-judgmental approach to the work we
do for us things really start with our
helpline it's available monday through
friday from 10 a.m to 6 p.m it's the
primary way that folks first connect
with us i like to say you don't need to
know what questions to ask just call and
our helpline responders can help you
figure out what's going on and the best
way to kind of navigate your situation i
think we have to remember that if you've
met one person who's living with or
affected by mental illness you've met
one person these are not easy um
situations to solve with a
one-size-fits-all approach it's very
individualized and person-centered
and so we like to start where people are
and connect them both internally to our
full array of programs and services all
of which are available free of charge
and also connect them to
very specific meaningful resources that
may exist outside of our wall so we keep
a really robust resource directory of
over 500 entries of programs and
services and resources within the new
york city area for different community
members for diverse communities for
different kinds of needs whether it's
legal assistance or housing
or any other employment anything that
you can think of really intersecting
with us we want to be a trusted resource
of people who understand and get it
because because of that that lived
experience and from the helpline it
really kicks off to evidence-based
education classes we have over 30
support groups that take place every
single month we do a lot of stigma
reduction work we go into schools and
community centers and companies
and we do a ton of advocacy and we're
recruiting folks to be to lend their
voices to these issues and these causes
to help shine a light on how many of us
are affected we say one out of five of
us is living with mental illness well
the other four are their family members
their friends their colleagues at work
their social networks their next door
neighbors so these issues really affect
all of us and when we find a way to talk
about what we're going through we
realize we're not alone we realize we
are part of a community that is deeply
impacted in these ways that other people
can really understand appreciate and
validate
that's so good i mean such an array of
just opportunities and i love the
framing too that it sounds like a lot of
it's an entry point the fact that you're
saying people don't need to know what to
ask i think it's powerful because i
think sometimes that can be a hesitation
not knowing what to ask even if it's you
know someone that you know who's
struggling or someone you know you may
be struggling yourself not knowing where
to start but to be able to have that
level of openness to try and figure out
what to ask the first place then to be
able to be plugged into all the
different resources and
programs that you all have and you
connect other people with too i think
that's really powerful and we definitely
need more of it
yeah and i think being treatment
adjacent and
having as wide a front door as we can
with as few barriers as possible and
really being of the communities that
we're connecting and serving allows us
to create a space where you don't have
to know the answers you don't have to to
you we just want you to call we just
want you to come just connect with us to
recognize uh that this is a journey
these are marathons not sprints
um and and anything we can do to provide
that kind of support i think sometimes
we live in a world today where there's
it's a little dangerous to make mistakes
in some ways to say the wrong thing or
to use the wrong word um and we want to
create a space where people can
can feel
vulnerable and safe exploring these
issues to figure it out because they're
so complex and there's so much nuance
and it's so
individualized that i don't want anybody
to feel the same that they can't sort of
discover what's going on discover on
this journey of how to help someone how
to help yourself while you're helping
someone um so we really try to just be
as open as we possibly can yeah i really
love that i mean the way that you're
inviting people in because it's tough
already so that that piece is huge to be
have that to be able to have that
openness and invitation to really
include so many folks in so many ways
yes
cory a pivot to you i know you've also
been involved in nami but then also have
a bit of your own story that you've been
walking through even before you know you
got involved in the organization so i
wonder if you could just tell us a
little bit about you know your path into
this work and the ongoing work that
you're doing as well
yeah i heard you say walking through and
i i feel like i was thrown into this
space you know like and i had to figure
it out uh like a fish out of water
flapping around because i was around 14
years old
when
we had to take my mother to the
emergency room she was talking nonstop
incoherent um she had the ideas of
grandiose uh
thinking that she had miraculous powers
and all of these things and so for me to
hear
that i did not know what was going on
and for me to not be able to
uh interact with her because it was i'm
talking to her but she wasn't talking to
me and it was like i wasn't there
but a family member came and we went to
the emergency room and that's when i
heard the diagnosis for the first time
manic depression paranoid schizophrenia
and manic depression now known as
bipolar disorder um but still that those
were just words didn't know what that
meant didn't know that that would
ultimately mean that she wouldn't be the
mother that i thought that i had or
would have for the rest of my life
um but it was a learning experience and
so from that age of 14
basically seeing my mother go in and out
of mental health institutions and by the
time i went to college i just was trying
to learn all that i could and my first
education piece if you would is a
television movie called out of darkness
uh that starred diana ross it came out
in 1994 but when i saw the previews i'm
like it looked very very familiar and
i'm like oh my gosh i need to watch this
like but i didn't know that that was
mental illness i didn't know that that
was some kind of way related to my
mother's diagnosis but as i continued to
educate myself
and then getting a master's degree that
wasn't because i wanted it necessarily i
wanted to learn more about mental
illness and what my mom was going
through and studying from the dsm-4 at
that time the five is out now but that
helped tremendously in in learning a bit
more and what could happen
uh what was available for my mom's
future as well as mine so with that
um once i started my career as a lawyer
my aunt my mother's sister who was very
instrumental in helping my mother as
well
she saw an article for nami in the
newspaper she clipped it out and put it
in my mailbox and she had a little note
on it saying i think this is something
you should uh go to
and it was the family the family uh
course it was 12 weeks at that time back
in 2009 and i went to it um i think i
was probably the youngest person there
the only person there who was there
because of a parent with severe mental
illness but all of our stories were so
similar so similar and we learned a lot
from each other as well as the course
and then as i continued in my career and
most of
my last 10 years of my career was in
public housing and we provide housing
for individuals with disabilities and
low-income families and seniors so
dealing with reasonable accommodations
and other things that are on the legal
side was giving me a whole another
aspect of advocacy for individuals who
are living with severe mental illness
ultimately you know i started helping to
raise money for our local nami chapter
through the walks that we would have and
i then wanted to get trained
and give back it was my way you know
someone took time out to provide these
free services for me and my family and
other families and i wanted to be able
to do the same so i did do the training
i
co-facilitated my first course and i
also participated for the first time um
and speaking to law enforcement as a
part of their in-service uh training
and sharing our lived experience and
helping them to um have strategies in
place procedures in place for helping
someone in crisis and things that they
can do and working with the family so i
think that's so important
especially in the black community and we
have concerns of calling the police we
want help but you don't know if anybody
is going to make it alive and those are
realities for us unfortunately and i
know i've had to call the police a
number of times on my mother and
today looking back on it i feel fear but
i'm grateful to god that nothing ever
happened to my mother and that we had
law enforcement officers and you know
individuals from community treatment
teams that helped um even when they
didn't have to help you know we i kind
of feel like i had an informal uh
network of people because they knew me
or knew they had my number they could
call me
and i could call them to try ultimately
to keep my mother safe even when her
behaviors weren't so safe towards me
yeah that's that's so important there's
so many
just key pieces that you just just
talked about i mean from the legal
aspect from what you've gone through as
a you know as a family member
to just having that support and having
teams in place
i think it's so um
encouraging to hear the way that you
have
walked it out in a sense and i know
walking isn't you know not the best way
to put it because as you mentioned you
were thrown into it but the fact that
you've been able to
take that throwing and turn it into a
journey that's really empowering so many
people i think is really
really uh uh amazing in a lot of ways i
know you know having heard you talk
elsewhere before that you definitely are
a proponent of the team approach and how
important that has been as well i think
that's a theme that cuts through the
work that both of you do in terms of the
these aren't things that are done in
isolation and a lot of ways you're
trying to get
folks out of that isolation to make sure
that there are ways to really um
approach this um as teams but i'm also
curious because both of you are so
involved in the work itself
do you think that permeates so i mean as
we were talking about before we came on
you know matt you mentioned as well one
in five
who are dealing with mental illness and
the other four probably know someone who
is but then i feel like there's also a
difference between those who are
actively in the midst of it and have all
of these components that you've talked
about and think about these things
deeply versus
some who aren't in the midst of it at
the moment and may have perspectives on
the outside um so when we talk about how
mental health is viewed as society do
you feel like there's a difference
between those who are kind of in the
midst versus the general
portrayal in society and if so are we
making progress and actually improving
that and making those two a little bit
more aligned
so i know that's a big question but yeah
from what i hear from what you're saying
i really feel that those any any of us
those who are in the work or not we're
part of the one in five we're a part
because that's any mental illness you
know depression and that any anything
that causes and i'm not a clinician i'm
a lawyer
but anything that causes heightened
emotional um
something you know
caught like it could be good stress or
bad stress right you know planning a
wedding that can be
great but it's also stressful but it's a
good stress right
uh having a death or um having issues at
work that could be like bad stress but
depending on how it impacts you it can
be from mild to severe right it just
would like depression so you know you're
not eating well you're not sleeping well
whatever your symptoms may be and i feel
like that is one the one in five but
severe mental illness one in 25
experience severe mental illness and
that's the biggest distinctions that i
can um that i have
that i recognize and
[Music]
uh are the hallucinations delusions and
anagnosia where the person doesn't even
have
knowledge
that they're sick and that can be very
very dangerous
it's very very difficult because you try
to communicate with your loved one you
see the behaviors they don't see the
behaviors and it can just be very very
complicated
but the biggest distinction for me for
any
mental illness versus severe mental
illness when you're dealing with the
hallucinations
and the delusions and anaknasia
any other thing that's impacting you
mentally
are things that we can perhaps have
outside treatment for we may not
necessarily need medication or we may
need to invoke more self-care and you'll
be able to deal with it but self-care
alone is not going to deal with severe
mental illness
and so i just caution people as
caregivers because the statistics are
alarming for caregivers and their own
health declining because of the stress
and strain of helping a whole nother
person in that person's life in addition
to your own
life work children family whatever your
responsibilities are and that of another
person and their hallucinations or
delusions if you're dealing with severe
mental illness but even with depression
if maybe in its most severe
forms you know causes a lot of stress
and strain on the caregiver as well so
with that i encourage people in whatever
work that they're doing that they
implement what is good for them in terms
of self-care that's not just going to
the spa and things of that nature but
meditation and sometimes it's just
chilling like just chill out
take a seat somewhere and chill out
that's really well said you have other
specific tools that you've encouraged
folks to use or even things that you've
used yourself um over the years
yes like walking sitting by water
you can listen there's so many apps that
are available now too like calm
um
headspace different things like that but
what i found and even counseling
on this because of my busyness i needed
to calm that down and be consistent you
know
for example what came
i now it took me three times to go to
counseling and for me to commit to it
once when i was a child unfortunately my
mother did attack me and i was removed
from the home and so part of the court
order was for me to go to counseling i
didn't like it i might have went to two
or three sessions i share this because
it's it's okay if your first time isn't
doesn't work out you know just try it
again maybe that counselor and you don't
jail that's fine
you don't you don't have to go to just
one um another time was when i was in
law school and i may have had like mild
depression then based on a survey right
but all of my responsibility at that
time would be you would think that you
know you probably are stressed out it
causes some level of depression i was a
new mother my son was potty training
when i started law school new wife
commuting to law school and law school
in general was just hard you know so i
did try it but maybe one session i did
not like it but the third time i'm still
with her today it's been about at least
10 years but what made it effective was
when i made the commitment to be
consistent with my appointments because
of everything else i was doing
counseling would be the first thing i
would cancel and i had to learn to not
operate out of crisis not to try to get
an appointment when i'm overwhelmed with
whatever i was dealing with in my life
but just having it as a constant on my
schedule not canceling it and going yeah
that's so important all those things
that you brought out just in terms of
doesn't always work on the first time
like you said having that persistence
and wanting to kind of
make it a priority too which is also not
easy and you're right i mean
people don't always gel so i think to
your point people shouldn't be
disappointed if it doesn't work out the
first time right there's room there's no
you know there and people have to be in
the right it has to be the right
combination just in terms of personality
and all the different types of styles
that different therapists use so just
being open to saying okay that style
that person might not have been the
right fit that doesn't mean we throw it
all out
so your example i think is great
i think it's like dating a little bit
yeah
it's about that fit it's about that fit
and not everybody is going to be what
you need in in that moment and i also
think that you know when you think about
therapy it tends to be a white middle
upper class sort of construct that that
other people from other cultures and
other diverse groups aren't used to
going to a stranger and talking about
what's going on inside of them that
they've maybe never said out loud before
to someone else so not only do we have
to help normalize that it's okay to talk
with people who are expert and trained
to help guide you through it uh which is
hard to convince people you know oh we
don't talk about that stuff outside the
family or we got this this is our
our problem to solve thanks anyway but
then you have to get people to realize
that it might not work on that first try
um and how important it is to find
someone who understands your experience
so that when you're talking about what's
going on for you they may not they don't
have to have literally experienced it
themselves but if they're if they don't
understand the culture the context of
where you're coming from it's going to
be a lot harder to really feel like
you're seen and heard in a way and you
don't want to have to explain you're
like i'm a gay man i don't want to have
to explain what that means to my my
straight therapist or right it just it's
it's a different starting point and i
think it's so important but if we think
i know a lot of people said oh i tried
it once not for me therapy not for me
you got to try it again i think it's
really important like corey said it may
not be that first shot for whatever
reason maybe it's not the person maybe
you're not ready for it but you gotta
you gotta keep keep giving it a shot if
you can i think yeah so well said and i
really appreciate that you know in your
role too that you're thinking about you
know that cultural competency like you
talked about so that people
can can engage with you on that too and
know that if that's missing that's a
huge component that can really
be that's important it needs to be part
of it so the fact that you
you are
making that plain and making it known i
think is really important as well
i was just going to say these
differences matter they really make it
matters a lot
after george floyd was murdered we
started a group called black minds
matter to create a space for people who
identify as black and living with a
mental health condition to come together
among those multiple levels of shared
experience
um
and i you know we heard from a lot of
people early on i've been waiting for
this kind of space to be here it's
unfortunate for us it took the murder of
george floyd to for that to happen
um
but since last summer it's really been a
consistent ongoing source of of support
where the people who attend that group
feel seen
their experience you know when you talk
about what you're going through and
people are nodding along because they
get it you feel you feel that you feel
validated and seen and normalized
and it's similar to what corey said
about being the only one in family to
family who was there for
a parent dealing with a parent
you can there's a lot of relatability
around having an ill relative but it's
different when it's your your parent
than it is if it's your spouse or your
adult child those relationships matter
it's the same thing all of those
sort of data points we really want to
make sure that there's connectivity
among them
so that people are getting the most out
of the experience of support
and giving it too right it goes in both
directions when you're in a group or a
class it's you're sharing and you're
being shared with and the power of that
is um really ex
exponentially i think increased
when you you relate to the people around
you when you feel seen and you feel
um that that shared experience yeah yeah
that's huge i think it goes a long way
in building that level of trust too it's
really important and moving forward in a
lot of ways
through the challenges because they are
challenging if the trust isn't there i
think it makes it that much harder for
people to really engage and cory sounds
like you all had that in the group too
just the the
relatability then it seems like there
was some level of trust that came with
that as well because oh these are other
people who can relate to what i've been
through and we can trust each other to
learn from each other about how to
navigate it which i think is really
important
and what i also found important um just
in the community because some people
don't want to identify with how they
know you
in the community um but when i guess
whether it's like an eye contact or it's
okay you know i want to give you a hug
because we know each other from nami you
want to make sure that you are
respecting people's um privacy and and
what they are willing to share outside
of the space um that's important as well
but
it's great to still have connections
with people who went through the program
yeah that's great to hear those continue
as well
and matt that's another thing yeah go
ahead
i was just going to say something that
goes back to the your question dr addy
around kind of the state of of things
now and
um and corey as you were talking um
about the distinction between mental
illness and serious mental illness and
um
one of the things that i've we've been
talking a lot about is how it this is
these issues they're not they're they're
not binary it's not all or nothing it's
it's it's far more spectrum than it is
um you know a
uh
a binary an all or nothing kind of of
thinking so you can have optimal um
mental health and still have experienced
symptoms of mental health challenges you
can be
living with a diagnosis of serious
mental illness and have really great
positive strong mental mental health so
the plot points on that on that those
quadrants
really i think help people see
that if you have a brain you have mental
health and your mental health is going
to be impacted in whatever goes on
throughout your day in positive ways as
cory was saying and in not so positive
ways and i think
everybody being forced to kind of live
through this i hope and it feels as if
there's a little bit of a ground swell
toward recognition
that it isn't us and then that we're all
on that spectrum we're all within that
continuum of that that that framework um
and how it doesn't take much to
negatively impact your mental health
wherever you are at baseline whether
it's living with serious mental illness
or not
um
and i hope that that
has
positively impacted
the space
through
[Music]
by people understanding how
um
[Music]
universal it really is yeah right it is
i mean because it doesn't discriminate
mental and i love that you use the brain
uh just saying it because i just said
this in a speech somewhere like anybody
that has a brain
has mental health right and then it's
the condition of it so i think about
legal forms that we have to fill out
especially with divorces right and one
of the questions is about your health
what would you put poor good excellent
that's essentially what the surveys are
and depending on what your numbers are
that could tell you whether you're mild
to severe and depression or whatever it
could be right and i would love it if we
could just have this um
more openness and it really does
attribute to stigma stigma it seems like
as soon as you say the word mental
we don't pause what you gonna say next
because i'm not connecting with that
word what are you gonna say
but we have to understand
people are so open to blurting out what
their physical conditions are and
physical ailments and whatnot but not so
much with the mental and so i say okay
just take mental and physical out of it
i'm having some health complications do
we need to know us with your mind or
with some other part of your body no
that's between you and your doctor but
what i am encouraging people uh the
words of bibi more campbell she is a
three-time new york times bestselling
author i claim her as my favorite author
but she was a tremendous advocate for
nami in california and started a chapter
in los angeles where she lived because
she was leaving her community to go to a
predominantly white area to get the
services from nami so
she's now deceased but at the same time
she would say you need to get a check up
from the neck up right we go get our
physicals hopefully everybody goes once
a year
why just stop here like go up as well
you can ask your doctor for a mental
health survey or inventory or whatever
they may call it and you can do that for
your children as well i was very very
pleased with the pediatrician's office
here when my son was younger they're
both adults now and happy international
men's day i must say
i've
i was going to send both of my sons a
text and just say it you know just to
say hi
that works that works
but at any rate um
you they have them available for
children as well we can't say oh they're
too young no we have to be proactive
don't operate out of crisis don't wait
until it gets to you know these
behaviors being okay now something has
to be addressed here you don't have to
get to that point be proactive when you
go for your physicals ask for a mental
health inventory as well it doesn't mean
that you have
concerns but if it identifies something
why not treat it why not find out what
you can do to help yourself versus
waiting till it gets to a bad bad place
which it could yeah
yeah definitely agree well i was a
neuroscientist who studies the brain i
agree with both of you and i'm actually
impressed that you both brought that up
before i did but i mean it's critical i
mean to be honest i think as
neuroscientists that's something we need
to do a lot better of in terms of
educating the public and saying well
there are things that are going wrong in
your brain that's going to have
consequences i mean we think about that
when we think about strokes
generally in society we don't think
about that when we think about things
like depression
or anxiety because there are so many
components that can lead to those things
but we tend to forget that that happens
through the brain like these experience
the experiences that we have impact our
brains which impacts how we approach
these situations um so i mean you're
both you're both experts in my mind
already but yeah that's something i've
shared with audiences as well too like
if i you know just based on the things
we study if i go
and i increase the levels of certain
brain chemicals in a certain way
more than likely that can push you into
one direction or another and lead to
depression early time so in the same way
i may always give the funny example you
know if someone broke their arm they
wouldn't just leave it and say oh i'm
just gonna kind of you know get some
counseling from my arm or pray over my
arm and then maybe it'll get better you
go to the doctor you get a cast but we
do that with our brains all the time
irrespective of what type of experience
may have caused that change in the brain
to occur but we sometimes just leave it
and don't actually address it so i love
that checkup from the neck up and all
those components
well i think doesn't our brain control
our whole body right
so we have to have it in optimum shape
and i think it is so connected to stigma
i think people don't think about it as
part of the brain or what because they
don't want to deal with it they don't
want it to be happening to them it isn't
real it is true if i just pretend to
ignore it and we know that that doesn't
work we know that that's not
that's not the case and i think when we
think about stigma so often we think
about creating a space where people feel
comfortable coming out about what
they're going through and i think we
also really need to create a sense of
inquiry where we are actually
feeling empowered um to say to someone
who
may seem like things are not going so
well to say hey are you okay i'm worried
about you it's not enough to say well do
we just have to create a world where
people feel comfortable coming forward
and talking about it if you're living
with serious mental health issues you
may not have the ability to talk about
it to come out and talk about it it's on
the rest of us those other four
to to to find a way to say i'm worried
about you are you okay how can i help uh
i think that's so important if we're
going to really move the needle on this
and kind of pull the curtain back yeah
yeah i definitely agree with you i think
another layer on that too is just the
the fear that comes with that too maybe
that's also fear of the unknown because
when it comes to the stigma obviously
but also our brains i think sometimes
there's a fear of well what is that
going to
entail and medication can be effective
but medication isn't the only way we
change our brains so i mean even things
like meditation change our brains being
in community changes our brains i mean i
think at this point in time a lot of us
have a better feel for that being in
isolation something felt different and
that's because of the effects that
community has on our brains and how it
engages certain reward pathways in our
brains that help us feel better and go
through our daily rhythms i mean there's
even studies looking at you know the
power of prayer and how that can impact
the brain and counseling can impact the
brain medication so we have to have an
approach where we take all these
different factors and obviously i'm
biased in focusing on the brain but as
corey mentioned the brain does control
our bodies so it's legitimate bias but
just you know think about all these
different components and ways that can
actually impact our brains and how we
interact with each other and not being
afraid to engage in those so i think you
know in a lot of ways as i'm talking a
lot there's probably more that we all
should be doing in partnerships with
this with the advocacy work with the
neuroscience to really bring these types
of conversations to the forefront so
people have a better understanding and
even try and move past the stigma in
that sense as well so just to give a
story i had given the talk years back at
the public library that i called the
neuroscience of addiction just to kind
of get a sense and help people
understand what happens when you have
exposure to certain substances for
periods of time and so people from the
community came to that there were also a
bunch of folks from a recovery house
that came to that as well and so that
turned into a really nice dialogue it
wasn't just me there kind of giving
didactic information but i was sharing
what we knew about the brain they were
also sharing from their experience so in
a sense we both learn from each other so
a lot of the folks you know some of the
folks walked in and said oh well i don't
really see this as an illness because i
did this to myself which at some level
is true you can't become addicted if
you've never used a substance in the
first place but by the end of the
session they said okay well now i have a
better understanding
of what my use has actually done to my
brain and how the brain i have now is
not the same as it was before so it also
gave them a sense of ownership of ways
to move forward to get to a new normal
without being stuck in a what you know
this is an illness and there's not much
i can do about so i mean i feel like
that was a really useful conversation
for both of us to be able to both sides
to be able to get to a better place of
understanding and also me as a scientist
not just talking about those things and
not thinking about how people are
experiencing
some of the things they're going through
whether it's with the medication or
medication associ assisted treatments
and all those types of things so because
i'm saying we need to have more more of
what we're doing right here and it can
really go a long way yeah and nutrition
as well we often leave that out but the
things we eat and drink just whatever we
consume
impacts our brain health and overall
physical health as well so we can make a
lot of changes just by um
being aware of what we are putting into
our mouths
that's so true
and it's so empowering too to recognize
that there are things over which i
actually have some control this isn't
happening to me um in every way i can
control my response to this and i think
what you know we do we have a group
called hearing voices for voice hearers
people who hear voices and some of them
are on medication some of them are in
counseling and treatment some are doing
both and some have said i don't want to
take medication i want to i can tolerate
the voices it's manageable it's not
having a negative impact on my life
right now and i'm okay with that so
there's there's a level of autonomy um
that people actually can have an agency
and power in how they're going to
approach this there's not again it's not
that one-size-fits-all approach to
getting well to doing better you have to
pay attention to what's going on for you
and really figure out what those to the
extent you can figure out what those
pieces are that are are your holistic
approach to treatment even through the
lens of self-care you know i feel like
self-care sometimes can feel so
prescribed like it's meditating yoga or
running well if you don't do any of
those three things you beat yourself up
for not doing it and then you're in this
negative cycle as opposed to self-care
you're doing self-harm so like corey was
saying i try to we try to think about
self-care is what do you need right now
to be okay and maybe it is just sitting
by the water and maybe it is yoga
meditation or running maybe it's just
crying or looking out the window at the
leaves falling off of the tree so it's
excuse me
we can we can play a part in in moving
that needle and where we are by using
the resources the tools the supports
that we have to create that that kind of
wellness approach for ourselves
yeah
definitely agree definitely all sudden i
love the examples too of just meeting
people where they are just but you know
even as you talk about some can tolerate
the voices some don't want the voice and
just saying well what it goes back to
the point corey is making as well i
think matt you're also making like what
do you need to actually navigate the
situation and that's a topic that came
up with the last guest as well sean
aston talking about his mom patty duke
and some of the challenges with the
language that was used in terms of
suffering versus navigating and the fact
that we can navigate through these
things and still be at a place of having
overall
health and and
um not gratitude
yeah wellness in our lives even if there
are some struggles that are going on in
the background and so i mean matt you
talked about the spectrum corey you
talked about the spectrum even if
someone has a serious mental health
challenge but is navigating in a way
that's still effective we can't ignore
that and we can't put that in a box of
oh this is still bad
or someone who's on there you know we
have to really just have a broader
perspective on these things and help
people navigate and thrive in a lot of
ways
and we don't hear those stories enough
we hear so many stories of people living
with mental illness who are not doing
well or people who are committing crimes
or doing
like wildly
inappropriate awful things who we assume
are living with mental illness but we
don't really hear stories of people
living with serious mental illness who
are doing all right they're doing well
there's so many ideas so many
misconceptions around what who lives
with mental illness and what it means if
you do and i think to normalize
the reality of it that recovery is real
that you can live a rich full life with
a diagnosis of mental illness serious
mental illness um
we need to tell more of those stories
about people who who are
are living well and not focusing on sort
of the negative or assumed
attributes of who's living with mental
illness yeah that's really well said and
those assumptions can lead to all sorts
of you know often those aren't even
correct and the ones that are the
minority of the cases get blown up
and get the exact right and the uh the
attention so i think it's really and
just perpetuate the misunderstanding and
and that that uh contributes to the
stigma and that keeps people who are
living with these issues in the shadows
so it's just this negative cycle yeah i
mean especially like with the violence
that you talked about because the
pervasive thought is that people with
mental illness are more likely to commit
those types of crimes which is
completely non-factual and false because
they're much more likely to be victims
than to be the ones but if you talk to
people in general public that's not the
current
understanding of things even though it's
completely incorrect
no not at all and i think
even further to that point um we're
assuming that like clearly someone who's
committing and this kind those kinds of
acts of violence are not doing well
there's something going on for them but
to just sort of label them as mentally
ill is such a gross injustice it's not
fair it's not fair to them it's not it
just
um shines the wrong light on on what
these issues are and who's living with
them
yeah
so as we wrap up i think we're also you
know touching on the many things that we
still have to do as a society so i'm
curious you know from both of you
obviously the work that you're doing is
so important is making a huge impact but
what do you see
as the next steps that we need to make
either within your organizations and
your initiatives or as a society in
general
not a small question
yes not a small question and there is
not a small answer but like we need an
overhaul to the mental health system it
is too difficult to get help and i feel
for those families that don't have help
or don't know where to go for help which
i'm trying to use my voice as much as
possible but also housing housing is one
of the first things that a person loses
dealing with severe mental illness as an
example because of the behaviors and
they may be interpreted as
violating lease terms for example but
having housing available quality housing
i've seen some deplorable conditions in
group homes and things of that nature
but they still get the full dollar for
an individual staying there so some of
the things that i want to work on is
just helping with um legislation that
can help
increase the quality of life for those
living with severe mental ill mental
illness as well as quality housing being
available with the understanding of you
know behaviors and how they can just
have the opportunity to live in in
quality i can't stress that enough
quality housing um
you know with property owners that
understand the behaviors that may be
exhibited at any given time
yeah so well said
and nami nyc uh we're really focused on
reaching underserved communities right
now uh and we're defining that in in
pretty broad ways so black and brown
communities of course also deaf and hard
of hearing communities the lgbtq
communities older adults non-native
english speakers we really want to make
sure that the programs and services that
we're offering not only do all
individuals understand what they are
that they're free and how easy it is to
access but that they again they feel
seen when they show up when they come
and they dip their toe in in the nami
nyc water so to speak uh and then we're
also focusing on the family piece the
family caregiver piece peace
we're continuing to provide programs for
people who are living with mental
illness and we always will but one of
the things we recognize is we're really
the only resource for family members
especially family members of adults
and so we want to make sure that
uh families know that there's knowledge
and skill and support that you can learn
from our 40-year history that can make a
meaningful difference not only in your
life and in the life of the individual
who you care so much about but in your
shared life you know so often we're
winging it and when we're winging it
there's a tremendous amount of tension
and friction that tears families apart
but it can be better it can be when we
know what to say what not to say when to
say it when not to say it how to say it
excuse me
to separate the person from from their
diagnosis and their symptoms and see
them separately so that i can hate
bipolar disorder but i love this person
uh we're really focusing on those on
those family pieces as well and then as
corey mentioned advocacy you know we can
have all the programs and services in
the world but if we don't improve the
mental health system and for us specific
we're working on five tenets but the one
i'll call out today is decriminalizing
mental illness um it's so critically
important for us to really move the
system to change the mental health
system so that it really can be mental
health for all
yes yeah
well said
well that wasn't an easy easy question
but i definitely appreciate both the
answers that you both mentioned and i
encourage listeners too to just uh reach
out to your local nami as well if there
are things resources you're looking for
or ways to get involved and to support
and of course even as you mentioned with
the housing any specific suggestions
corey for listeners in terms of ways
that they may be able to get involved in
some of these fights from a legal
perspective
yes contacting their local
representatives state representatives as
well as their federal um legislators and
finding out nami is very good it has an
advocacy uh piece on their website where
they can let you it tells you about
pending legislation and how to
communicate with your
congress member and it's just important
for us to know
that these things are important the
emails the phone calls
they are important so we may not think
we're making a big impact because it's
just one phone call from us but you can
get your family and friends to do it as
well and if there's ever a hearing that
you can go and sit in and even be able
to speak i suggest you please let people
know that you are willing to to do that
and share how important some of these
pieces of um legislation are especially
with the um
exclusion i'm sure you can give me is it
the imd exclusion
for the beds there's like a limit on the
number of beds that are available in
order for a refund to occur to that
local entity it's a it's just
unfortunate that it's all about money
when you have real lives that are being
impacted and need the services um so i
just encourage individuals to go to
organizations websites like nomi like
mental health america like the treatment
advocacy center and look at their
legislation and policy and procedure uh
piece because they they have so many
things already in place templates you
can use to help you to be able to
communicate with legislators who can
make a difference and the time is now to
make that difference
that's great advice
well thanks so much to both of you for
the time taking the time out to join the
adios for sharing all these wealth of
resources with our listeners and sharing
your experiences and your advocacy as
well definitely appreciate your time and
the work that you all do and i think
we'll have to
follow up and continue this conversation
at some point
thank you thank you for having me i
really appreciate it and i do want to
share also with your listeners that they
can go to
coreympowers.com i put together a my
go-to mental health guide and again me
just coming in raw with this and just
wanting to learn all i can but it has
movies and books blogs apps just
different things that you can go to at
your leisure to find out more you know
if it's someone you're dating someone
you're married to or a family member or
your child or yourself and you want to
know more please look into it don't just
try to ignore things because
more than likely is not going to go away
find out what you can do now find out
more about treatments that are available
and resources that are available as well
so that's at corianpowers.com
my go-to mental health guide really
important i'm so grateful you've put
that together
yes thank you
excellent yeah it's great to be here
such a pleasure to get to know you corey
and hear about all the amazing things
you're working on yes it's a pleasure to
meet you as well matt and i look forward
to staying in touch with you
likewise
excellent thanks to both of you again
[Music]
you